is there a place for you is it the
shower the bathtub where suddenly your
mind just zones and then music starts
flooding in when I sit down to do my
makeup cuz I've got the table there I've
got my makeup laying around and I've got
my notepad there and my little tape
recorder somehow just when I'm looking
at myself putting on makeup you know my
mind is working everything is kind of
work my hands are working and somehow
there's just something about that time
of the morning and when I'm doing that
that I get some of my best ideas the
mornings are always best for me I always
try to keep a little U tape recorder
somewhere near cuz if I get a Melody
that's the same as like words if you
don't write it down you're going to
forget it you'll think you'll remember
it but you won't sometimes I'll dream a
song and I learned years ago if you
don't wake up and write that down you
will not remember that the brain does
not retain ideas it's a good place for
dreaming ideas you've got to write them
down I think all writers do that ser
serious songwriters we'll ride on a
tablecloth we'll ride on a napkin on a
Kleenex box whatever you know it's handy
and I'll use a Maybelline pencil
anything I get my hands on cuz I know if
I don't do it right then I will forget
it and then I'll want to kill myself
later to think what was that great idea
I know it was great so you just learn
that's part of your trade don't take
anything for granted if this is your job
you do it and you do it
good